what's up gq i'm joe keary and today i'm
going undercover on the internet
it is actually me
[Music]
seriously it is actually me
[Music]
twitter i've seen some on-set photos of
stranger things 4 on tumblr and i have a
big question why is joe curie covered in
blood what
happened or will happen to steve again
well
it's a theme at this point on the show
that they always beat me up you know
they're kind of always tossing me around
you know you can expect some consistency
in that way i guess is uh all i'll say
if i were to reveal anything
they would really beat me up
read it
read it we love reddit oh this is
excellent i wish i could have been a fly
on the wall when they tell jokiry that
this is what he'd be wearing all season
yeah that's pretty much my face that i
was making i think the only moment of
real panic i had was when i was there on
my first day of shooting i put
everything on i went through makeup and
then i like looked at myself and i was
like man
this will never go away
and i've got a little worried but
now i'm really not so worried and i kind
of really like the sailor outfit those
shorts fit me
better probably than any shorts have
ever fit me so yeah is stranger things
is
joe keary this generation's ashton
kutcher
i don't know tbd to be seen tvs i am
gonna be doing a steve jobs movie just
dana's
how to make my hair as good as joe
kiri's get sarah hines gall to cut it
and style it every single uh day on set
she's the genius i don't know what she
does otherwise i'd do it joe carey did
you make any of the music and spree no i
did not i was james ferraro um who is a
great musician but that was something
that was actually most helpful i had a
playlist of some of his music and some
of the demos that he was making for the
film
and listening to that music
it's very chaotic
and it's very [ __ ]
and just felt really right to listen to
that when getting ready for the
for the movie this is at zayn's blonde
beard
nice does joe curie run the kurt kunkel
instagram account
no i do not that is in fact well maybe
i'll just leave it as a mystery i'll
leave it as a mystery
youtube
why the hell does everyone say steve
became a mom in season two because
off-screen i gave birth to triplets
during the filming of that season so i
actually am a mom bromance
bromance is that really a thing to say
about a mom raising his son now this
isn't so gayton actually isn't uh one of
my uh
yeah the public has never seen my
children yeah people went really crazy
with this people want to say i'm a mom
i guess they can it is
quite weird
wikipedia
after graduating from depaul my alma
mater that is true kiri went on over
a hundred auditions a lot of no's and
one yes and that's
why i'm here i'm pretty good at not
getting the things i'm very excited
about so i try to be as least excited as
possible as i can about the things that
i really like try to
you know reverse engineer the universe
in that way in his early 20s kiri
released music under the name cool cool
cool that is true i just it was a couple
songs messing around
before i met my uh
band buddies in chicago the post animal
guys who are the best over to the
youtube comments funny why does every
time joke here get hurt in the show he
has a bruise in his eye
i ask myself the same question
i have very sensitive eyes i wear
glasses but i don't wear contacts
because i don't really like getting
getting in there every time they have to
get in there it's i'm not looking
forward to that so we should start a um
not a gofundme what is that petition
page to just
end bruises in my eye petition.org we
gotta take it up with the duffers gotta
end this it's been enough enough is
enough can we talk about how joe is the
only american celebrity to do a great
australian accent oh man to be put on
the spot well i shot with daker
and daker's uh
always going mate
night so taker gave me some tips like a
lot of bands from australia so i've seen
a lot of interviews too it's me for real
why is no one talking about joe's
cardigan don't think that's a cardigan i
just think that's a shirt that thing is
dope
like
i'm a steve harrington fan as much as
the next bloke but damn joe curie
where'd you get that cardigan i think
it's a shirt i think it's just a regular
shirt and it was a outfit for press i
can't quite remember what it was whoever
created it probably will never allow me
to wear one of their things again
because of uh this because i can't
remember the name of it okay back to
twitter when are we getting a biopic
about the everly brothers starring
rejected jokes ben schwartz and joe kiri
i mean come on you know we kind of do
look like them actually a lot yeah
that's crazy maybe this will give this
thing some legs and we can actually make
this thing happen i've been waiting for
this project to come along
instagram
where's the album
not done still
figuring that out shout out to bendick
uh who did the art for this huge fan of
uh todd i think it's teurs or terrier
i'm not quite sure i pronounced it but
love that album that's how i met uh
bendick art is amazing
lovely guy yeah working on it hopefully
it'll happen soon or ever we'll see what
your hogwarts has joe
um
good question i have read all those
books obviously
probably would be
probably hufflepuff maybe i don't know
we'd have to get the sorting hat out
here for that hey joe what do you think
about being a survivor and dead by
daylight by the way you're my favorite
character in stranger things and i play
as you in dead by daylight i have seen
uh photos of this yeah the brothers
showed me photos of this on set i think
it's really kind of crazy i have not
played this game but maybe i should i
think natalya is also a character so it
probably plays natalia's character kind
of weird to be a video game character
okay guys thank you for the questions
love answering them but i'm signing off
of the internet
bye bye